Speaker 1: Let's go next to
how about Dan from California?
Dan from California. Welcome to the
program. What's on your mind today?
Speaker 2: Hi, David. I do a lot of
debates and discussions on my YouTube
channel. I've done some with Sam Cedar, and
I was wondering if you would ever be up for
a long form debate. I'm a big Ayn Rand fan,
so that's the perspective I'm coming from.
Speaker 1: What would the debate be about?
Speaker 2: It'll be about politics or ethics.
I do those topics a lot. Capitalism or ism.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I mean, maybe, you know,
I'm really limiting my appearances elsewhere just
because I'm so busy. And to be totally honest.
You might your channel might have 5 million
followers. I don't know. And this is not how
I base my decisions. But very often there's like
very little upside and it just it dominates my
schedule. You know, I want to have as clear a
schedule as possible. So like, maybe the way to
request that would be to email in.
Speaker 2: Might it make a
difference if I offered to pay?
Speaker 1: No, it really wouldn't.
Speaker 2: Okay. Yeah.
Speaker 1: I mean, like, how much would it
be worth to you? I don't know. Maybe it should.
Speaker 2: I don't know, like 100 bucks
for that. No, no, I'm kidding.
Speaker 1: I'm kidding around.
It would not make a difference unless
the amount was way higher. Dan, please.
Speaker 2: Okay.
Speaker 1: Now, I'm kidding around.
I might do it, but I'm really I'm really limited
in what I'm doing just because I'm so busy. What
is what would be your biggest gripe with my
perspective, I guess, is my first question.
Speaker 2: I guess one fundamental issue
which probably underlies political issues
is your ethics. So I don't I don't know what your
view on ethics is, but do you think people have
a moral rights to live for their own sake?
That would be one key question. Or should
they be forced to sacrifice for other people?
Speaker 1: Yeah. See, this is this is another
reason why I tend not to do these sorts of
debates. I exist in a place where I find many
of those questions. Do people have a right to live
for themself or should they be forced to sacrifice
for others? Well, the first question is what
kinds of societies do we even believe are best
or advisable? And one of the unfortunate not maybe
unfortunate, but like when I hear that question,
Dan, and this is why these often end up being
philosophical black holes, one of the biggest
things when I hear that question is if we start
from the point that we have societies of more
than 150 people, quite frankly, and more than a
thousand, right, The US has 330 million people,
it almost seems not super relevant. Whether I
think that in some theoretical context we have
a right to live for ourselves or should be quote,
forced to live for others. If we want to be in
this type of society, we are going to centralize
some aspects of society and the economy while
hopefully finding a balance that still allows
people reasonable amounts of self-determination.
If that if for me, I start there because this is
the society I live in, and if I don't like that,
I would then look at, okay, maybe I need to find a
different society where the dichotomy you raise is
actually feasible. It's less interesting to just
abstractly discuss the dichotomy you bring up. I
don't think we get much out of it, if that's fair.
Speaker 2: I think taxes, you know, that exists
in our society. So we all have to deal with
that. That's a case where I would say we're
forced to sacrifice what we would choose to
do with our own money for the sake of other
people. So I think it is very relevant to our we.
Speaker 1: Go I mean, on taxes, you're not forced
to work, right? Like you could choose not to work.
Speaker 2: Yeah, but if you do choose to work,
you're forced to give away some
of your earnings to other people.
Speaker 1: But you said if you choose to what
you did say, if you choose to work right,
choose is different than force. You acknowledge
that. Okay. And if you don't like the tax
structure of the United States, you could look
to go to a different place. I understand it's
difficult to stop paying taxes to the United
States, but there are different conventions.
You could renounce your citizenship, etc..
Like you agree that you could also kind of
take your take your toys and leave to some degree.
Speaker 2: Yeah, but I don't think the government
has the right to put you in that kind of
position. The government's right to tax.
I don't think it has a right to tax. It only has
rights that are delegated to it and its citizens.
But the citizens themselves don't have a right to
coerce others so they can't delegates the right
to coerce others to the government.
Speaker 1: Okay. So basically it's
like you're kind of like a standard
utopian libertarian, it sounds like.
Speaker 2: I'm not a utilitarian,
I'm an objectivist. Utopian. Utopian.
All right. Well, it's all very.
Speaker 1: Interesting, Dan. Listen,
if people hear this and think it would be
interesting for me to do 3 hours on this,
let me know and then I'll do Dan's show. And Dan,
you can email in and give me more info. Okay?
Speaker 2: All right. Thanks, David. All right.
Speaker 1: There goes Dan, an Ayn Rand fan. And
listen, we'll look into it. It's just not
usually like the best use of anybody's
time. That's been that's been my experience,
which is why I kind of tend tend not to do it.